[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
the parkland school shooter penalty
phase trial he had a big well right now
i know it's a backpack but for me in
that time it was a case hear from the
uber driver who deliver the gunman to
the school and just weeks after the
murder conviction is overturned
prosecutors want another trial for tex
mciver plus jury selection begins in the
first of several defamation trials
against alex jones and later brad pitt
versus angelina jolie which a-list actor
won the latest round as the pair face
off in a legal battle lawn crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to lawn crime daily i'm
your host brian buckmark the penalty
phase trial of the parkland school
shooter enters week two as jurors hear
from more survivors of the massacre and
the woman who drove the shooter to the
school
17 people were killed and 17 more
injured when a then 19 year old gunman
opened fire at marjory stoneman douglas
high school in 2018. in october of last
year the shooter pled guilty to 17
counts of murder and 17 more counts of
attempted murder which prompted his case
to head straight into the penalty phase
it's now up to a broward county jury to
decide whether the shooter is sentenced
to life in prison or given the death
penalty on monday jurors heard from
another survivor of the massacre
21-year-old justin colton he explained
he was just a freshman in high school
when he was shot and injured
i was in fourth period
just sitting there writing an essay and
then
heard loud sounds like the gunshots and
then
everyone began to run in the classroom
um i had ran towards the back towards
the teacher's desk
and i was on the ground uh
i had my hand and i was crawling against
the ground
okay and then what happened and then um
we sat there for about
20 minutes or less than 20 minutes
probably and then um
the police had came into our classroom
and escorted us out
you get shot yes all right when did you
get shot and where did you get shot
um when i was sitting or sitting or
running towards the back of the room in
uh
my right arm in my lower right back okay
so what what happened as a result of
your injuries
um i have a couple fragments still in my
lower back and then um i have a scar on
my arm as well
jurors also heard from laura zucchini
the uber driver who dropped the shooter
off at marjory stoneman douglas high
school
i picked him up and he comes in the car
and he told me and he told me
he was going to his music class
and that's all okay he said he was going
to music class did he have anything with
him
yes he had a big well right now i know
it's a backpack but for me in that time
it was a case
a guitar case he asked me if i was you
know
he i was
from the neighborhood so from the area
right i know i told him no that that i
pick up some passengers and
drop off in the area that's all okay and
uh did you observe what he was doing if
anything while he was in the back seat
of your uh rav4 well he was on on the on
the phone
joining us today is la county deputy
public defender philip duve and co-host
terry austin phillip on monday jurors
were shown the ar-15 the shooter used to
carry out the attack what kind of impact
do you think that could have on the
jurors
oh the visual impact alone is going to
be that when the jury
actually sees
this semi-automatic
rifle that has enough firepower to
and with enough ammunition can take out
an entire city block
the jury is going to know beyond a
reasonable doubt at least two of the
aggravators one of them is that uh he
committed murder by way of aggravated
child abuse and the other way or the
other aggravator
is uh that an act was committed that
created created a great risk of death to
others so when they bring this gun in
and the jury is to view that classroom
and they see the firepower of that
firearm the people or the prosecution is
going to be able to prove both of those
aggravators yeah philip i know you and i
have been there where they bring a gun
into a courtroom and the whole jury kind
of holds their breath as a defense
attorney not that great but in this case
i think uh the prosecution's doing well
terry how did the testimony from the
driver add to the prosecution's argument
that the parkland shooter deserves the
death penalty
well philip mentioned those aggravators
there are seven of them and i think what
the prosecutor is trying to do is to
show that it was cold calculated and
premeditated and also that he
intentionally was trying to disrupt a
governmental function like a school the
uber driver she actually said he told
her to strive a certain way and to go to
the school so i think he's trying to
show it's premeditated i thought it was
also interesting that the defense
attorney asked a couple of questions she
hasn't been really asking any questions
but she said
did he ask for a pool car and was he
nervous i think she's trying to show
that he wasn't pre-meditated and he
wasn't calculated that he was actually
nervous and he could have been in the
car with other people
i mean i know what i'm doing on this
show but i still get nervous i don't
know if premeditation and nerves uh one
can eliminate the other but we'll see
how that plays out in this the parkland
school shooter's death penalty phase
also in florida where authorities have
taken down a large-scale drug
trafficking ring allegedly led by a
former state correctional officer
ex-officer guard christina guess along
with her alleged supplier richard morris
campbell and several others were
arrested last month now charged with a
slew of felonies including trafficking
and conspiracy in total at least 10
people were taken into custody all
allegedly involved in what investigators
are calling the guest organization
investigators say the organization is
believed to have trafficked up to 80
pounds of methamphetamine over the last
year guest was previously arrested and
sent to prison on similar charges police
say when she was released she got back
into the drug trafficking at a press
conference officials announced the drug
ring is responsible for at least one
death a child who died late last year
identified in this investigation is a
female by the name of andrea dunmeyer
in december of last year we went to her
house where her infant child was found
deceased
we began an investigation into that
matter and determined that that child
died as a result of methamphetamine
toxology
we're not sure exactly how that occurred
our homicide detectives are continuing
that investigation and we're working
with the state attorney's office to hold
her accountable for that we don't
believe that it was an intentional act
but likely through neglect you know it's
sad you think about
we know about the child who died as a
result of
of
the meth
but what we don't know about that that's
the the sad part you know this this drug
is extremely addictive it ravages
families it tears families apart
children are ultimately the ones that
suffer from this because they're going
to go without while their parents are
out
trying to
feed their drug habits so it's it's
heartbreaking
still ahead on law and crime daily the
alex jones defamation trial begins in
texas after the far-right broadcaster
called the sandy hook school shooting a
hoax
but first just weeks after his murder
conviction is overturned georgia
prosecutors called for another trial of
tex mciver
[Music]
welcome back a georgian man could soon
be retried for the murder of his wife
this comes a month after the state's
highest court overturned his initial
conviction four years ago claude tex
macgyver was convicted in the shooting
death of his wife diane the couple was
driving home from a party with a friend
in 2016 when macgyver allegedly shot his
wife through the car seat as he sat
behind her during the trial there was
testimony that macgyver shot the gun as
a result of being startled awake and
that he suffered from a sleep disorder
which could have caused involuntary
movements he was convicted of murder and
sentenced to life in prison but the
state supreme court last month ruled
jurors should have been allowed to
consider a misdemeanor involuntary
manslaughter charge not only murder now
the fulton county district attorney is
planning to retry macgyver on felony
murder aggravated assault with a deadly
weapon and possession of a firearm
during the commission of a felony he
remains in jail serving time for the one
charge not overturned influencing a
witness
terry with a prosecution looking to
retry macgyver the defense filed a writ
of habeas corpus what is that and why
well brian you know interestingly enough
i took four years of latin i don't
remember much of it but i do know that
that means to show me the body meaning
that the defendant is going to be
protected here against any sort of
unlawful or indefinite imprisonment he
has a constitutional right to be treated
fairly and so technically he will be
brought into court he'll be delivered
there by the prison and the court will
hold a hearing and the court will have
to then determine whether or not he
should be detained and i think here the
court is probably going to say no he
doesn't need to be detained he's already
served a majority of his five-year
sentence remember he was sentenced for
influencing a witness so he'll probably
be let out of court while he waits for
this additional trial yeah so that's him
that's what's going to happen before
this potential trial happens phillip my
question for you is what's going to
happen in the trial because does the
prosecution have to change the way they
will prosecute the case after the
supreme court's decision and could we
expect a plea or a trial in this in this
uh in this case
well it just depends on who's
prosecuting it but legally of course
they could always offer him something
you know time served to an involuntary
manslaughter and the reason why his
conviction was reversed was because the
trial court aired based on a very
sufficient showing of evidence that what
he did was an act of involuntary
manslaughter which under georgia law is
a form of criminal negligence and all it
means is that it was an unintentional
killing committed uh by uh by an uh a
non-felony act
or that he committed a lawful act that
resulted in death and his story was that
he was startled out of his sleep and he
had a gun in his lap in the car while
driving through a rough neighborhood and
the gun discharged so the prosecution
may have two more charges to prove up to
a jury all right we'll see how that
contains that of course law and crime
daily we'll give you those updates as
that case continues heading west to
california the father of kristen smart
takes the stand as her accused killer
and his father are tried for her murder
smart went missing in 1996 when she was
a student at cal poly she was last seen
with paul flores at an off-campus party
several days later she was reported
missing while smart's remains have never
been found she was legally declared dead
in 2002. the case went cold for years
until the podcast your own backyard
reignited interest in smart's
disappearance in 2021 father and son
paul and ruben flores were arrested in
connection to smart's murder as
prosecutors believe smart's body was
buried and then in their yard but later
moved
paul is charged with smart's murder
while ruben is charged with accessory
after the fact accused of helping hide
smart's body
last week smart's father took the stand
as the prosecution's third witness stan
smart testified that he had visited the
flores family home several times but has
never stepped foot on the property
testimony resumed monday the trial is
expected to last for months
coming up on law and crime daily a legal
win for angelina jolie as she faces off
against ex-husband brad pitt plus jury
selection begins in the defamation trial
of alex jones for comments in the
infowars host made calling the sandy
hook school shooting a hoax
[Music]
welcome back jury selection begins in
texas in one of the defamation trials
involving alex jones after the infowars
host previously called the 2012 sandy
hook elementary school shooting a hoax
in december of 2012 a gunman killed 20
first grade students and six staff
members at the connecticut school after
the shooting jones told his audience it
was fake and used actors aimed at
increasing gun control the trial in
austin texas where jones lives and
broadcasts his show will determine for
the first time how much he must pay the
shooting victims families courts in both
texas and connecticut have already found
jones liable for defamation the
beginning of the trial comes after
months of delays
after jones ignored several court orders
and put infowars into bankruptcy
protection this first trial is just the
beginning for jones and his sandy hook
conspiracy as damages have yet to be
awarded in separate cases in connecticut
jones has since said he believes the
shooting happened but claims he had a
right to say it didn't opening
statements are scheduled to begin
tuesday
terry why is the trial in austin texas
of all places
well you know a court has to have
personal jurisdiction over the defendant
and jurisdiction will exist if the
defendant lives there or if he conducts
substantial business in that state and
it's in austin texas because guess what
that's where alex jones lives and that's
where he broadcasts his show so that's
the perfect place to bring this sort of
trial and it seems that he's going to
quickly be assessed with damages he's
already been found liable because he's
failed to respond to any of the court's
notices thus far so i think he is in for
a lot of money damages and off to a bad
start as far as he's concerned if anyone
knows why we're in austin it's going to
be terry austin thank you for that
philip alex jones is a politically
polarizing figure does this create
challenges in jury selection and how can
those be resolved
well there's a couple of things he can
do first of all he can take advantage of
what i call the home field advantage you
know if he's going to be tried by a
local jury there in austin where he's
from you know they might uh you know
have a little sympathy for him because
he is a local revered icon even though
he is controversial he will try to pick
a jury that recognizes the importance of
opinion and satire under our first
amendment in other words he's not really
stating his opinion as an affirmation of
fact
uh but it's understood that the audience
didn't
take it seriously or really didn't
really believe what he was saying that
it really was a form of satire and
entertainment uh additionally you know
there's what's called the halo effect
and that means that sometimes when
people have good attributes
you know because of prominence or
because of celebrity uh jurors tend to
enshrine that person with those simple
qualities and give them the benefit of
the doubt all right we'll see how jury
selection and ultimately the case goes
for alex jones will keep eyes on it as
it develops a mississippi police chief
is fired when a racist audio recording
is leaked lawn crime network's sierra
gillespie has the story
you kill them cold blood i will
articulate to fix the problems a
shocking confession caught on tape as a
mississippi police chief brags about
killing 13 people in the line of duty
all while using racist slurs
shot and killed in the line of duty 13
different people
okay
i mean i saved 67 kids and a supervisor
would show like 319 times
but he was here
119 times by me audio obtained by the
mississippi center for investigative
reporting through civil rights
organization julian features a recording
of lexington police chief sam dobbins
the audio was obtained by another
officer robert lee hooker who called it
quote appalling racist hateful and
detrimental to the welfare of the people
hookah resigned from the lexington pd
last week citing a toxic work
environment in late july the lexington
board of aldermen voted to fire dobbins
an interim police chief has since been
appointed reporting for long crime
network i'm sierra gillespie
when we come back it's angelina jolie
versus brad pitt who won the latest
round as the celebrity x's face off in
court
welcome back to long crime daily inmate
casey white is indicted on new federal
charges in connection to his jailbreak
with now deceased correction officer
inmate casey white and corrections
officer vicki white were last seen
leaving the lauderdale county jail in
alabama in may investigators say the
pair was not related but believe they
developed a romantic relationship while
spending time together the couple was on
the run for days sparking a nationwide
manhood that ended with a high-speed
chase and a crash in evansville indiana
vicki white later died in the hospital
in early july white was indicted on
felony murder charges alleging that
while committing first-degree escape he
caused the death of vicki white now he's
also indicted on charges of illegally
possessing firearms at the time of his
escape in celebrity news a win is
granted to angelia and jolie as she
faces off against ex brad pitt in a
legal battle over their wine company
the legal trouble begins with the once
shared chateau mobile a 164 million
dollar company and vineyard in the south
of france before their 2016 divorce a
couple equally split shares of the
business after that pitt says they may
have packed not to sell out their shares
without their partner's consent pitt
says jolie ignored the agreement when
she unlawfully sold her half of the
business to yuri shelfler a russian
businessman pitt called for a jury trial
back in june saying jolie worked to
undermine her ex-husband by forcing him
into business with a quote a stranger
with poisonous associations and
intentions jolie's team later subpoenaed
documents from pitt his business manager
and company last friday a california
judge ruled in favor of jolie saying
pitt must turn over the documents to his
ex-wife the judge also ruled the
documents need to be turned over even
before pitt's team could appeal the
decision
philip jolie has won the legal battle to
get the documents from pitt his business
manager and as i said his company bondo
bongo why do you think she would want
those documents though
oh the root of all evil money
you know they got married if i recall in
california which is a community property
state and assuming they didn't have a
pre or a post-nuptial agreement or what
we call a transmutation here where brad
or angie has separate property that they
later transmute to community property
you start suing guess what you're going
to file a cross complaint for 50 of the
community property she's probably trying
to figure out what the assets of mongo
bongo were so she can you know
make a claim for her share
it's fair game under california
community property law
i think that's different than new york
and i'm very happy about that terry does
this open a possibility for pitt to
subpoena joey's records and how public
will private finances become if this
continues
well all is fair in love and war and i
do believe pitt is probably going to
file for some discovery tit for tat
listen it's not a substantive decision
it's a decision that's really process
oriented of course they're going to get
documents from each other and it's going
to be by merely financial documents
because we do need to see how much was
in both accounts and they're going to
have to bring all of that out now sadly
i think they're going to be airing their
dirty laundry out in front of the public
because they are now on trial and it's
one of those cases where they could have
easily settled this in a separate
private affair
it's interesting that they didn't go
that route well
phillip terry a pleasure as always and
thank you for joining us here on lawn
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you